hey i have an idea how about i make that  lasagna that you love tonight  you know from scratch like i used to  live i used to work for some very  dangerous people  [Music]  they came after my family they stole my  kitty cat bracelet  and you don't do that give me that kitty  cat bracelet  it's the hell of a day nobody  in theaters only april 2nd rated r hey i  have an idea  how about i make that lasagna that you  love tonight  you know from scratch like i used to  live i used to work for some very  dangerous people  [Music]  they came after my family they stole my  kitty cat bracelet and you don't do that  give me that kitty cat bracelet  it's been a hell of a day nobody in  theaters only april 2nd rated r